hello everybody time again for the movie
retrospective doing kind of a newer film
this time around from 2014
it is Dracula untold yeah this one was
sent to us by a subscriber and the
picture and a patron and a personal
friend we put out the offer that if
somebody were where to send us kind of
like a factory copy of the DVD or bluray
of any movie that will we'll review it
yeah and we will eventually get around
to reviewing yeah so this one was sent
by Sophie thanks Sophie yes she said
it's - we're gonna do another one -
we're gonna do yeah that'll probably be
in a couple of weeks yeah
but yeah so cuz like I said I you know I
do like to do new ones sometimes but I
mostly like to do old ones so I'm gonna
like yeah and if it's not in our
collection you want us to review it just
contact us on Facebook we'll give you an
address you can send us a copy factory
copy only we don't do the burnt it gotta
be factory copy
Oh something I will put in my collection
sometimes well sometimes the burned ones
won't play in the Xbox yeah that's part
of my problem before but yeah so it's
not then you depend on our choice yeah
alright so Dracula untold was actually
like I said it came out in 2014 was
actually directed by Gary Shore this was
his feature film debut prior to this he
had only done like commercials and stuff
and I think the only film be done and
I'm not sure if he did it before this or
after this was if you guys have seen the
horror movie called holidays which is
either on Netflix or shudder I can't
remember I just saw it like a little
while ago he directed the st. Patrick's
Day short yeah so there's that whole
thing but like I said this was his first
film now the idea for this movie has
actually been floating around since
about 2007 right um initially it was
called Dracula Year Zero but they were
always kind of to conceiving it yes I
was like thank God they changed that
that is so cheesy but um originally
they're conceiving it as a Dracula
origin story which it is which that's a
good idea because it is you watch
Dracula and he does mention
you know his battles with the Turks and
yeah he mentioned stuff but you never
find out how he became a vampire
why he'd really became a man but as you
said it's a curse yes by God but then
what did he do with it right well that's
what this is all about explains how he
became this vampire and why and what he
did with it yeah yeah it like it hits a
couple of the same story beats as like
the Francis Ford Coppola Dracula but
obviously that was based on the novel
whereas this is pretty much straight up
based on Vlad tepish if glad tepish went
to a cave and became a vampire
yeah and by it was a legendary Studios
or legend studio yeah the same guys it
did 300 yeah and get involved in it
later on yeah yeah 300 was an awesome
film I liked it but the ones that came
out after in that same style they just
they just the scripts just weren't as
good and really watching this one when
that when that the studio label came up
of ledge is it legend or legendary yeah
was like oh man this is prime not gonna
be good to my surprise movies [ __ ]
awesome hot sauce ended up enjoying this
quite a bit I didn't know until
afterward um it actually was pretty
successful at the box office made over
200 million dollars worldwide on a
budget of only 70 million so it did
pretty well and they're talking about
maybe doing a sequel and stuff like that
um reviews were kind of mixed a lot of
people thought it was kind of meh or it
wasn't like as fun as it could have been
or something like that what they're
talking about but yeah some of the
reviews were like well they're trying to
do like a superhero movie but with
Dracula and it's like it's you know it
should have been more fun than that this
is a perfect at home watch either you're
streaming and are you watching on
blu-ray on you on a damn you know on a
new you know Smart TV you know you
drinkin yeah and you're watching it's
just perfect you know perfect for that
kind of thing ya can't not everything is
gonna be a masterpiece this is just a
solid flick but like I said I don't know
or just I'll say right here it gave me
an underworld and Van Helsing
vibe but I liked it exponentially better
than I liked those two yes I'm gonna one
thing I liked about it was the motif it
had it really did look like some
from from Villa Kia which is common
picture of Europe and Turkey really in
those divisional II it was super cool
but people to say yeah what they were
wearing and the armor yeah it looked
really cool really cool look at it was
actually I think the whole thing was
shot in Northern Ireland actually so the
main guy that's in it
Luke Evans played him he wasn't the
original guy that was suppose he was
like the second one to come in also the
guy that plays the villain the Sultan or
whatever
that's a Dominic Cooper and like the
whole time I was like where do I know
that guy from and then like after where
I was like oh it's preacher dur yeah
he's been another stuff to you but I
know I'm from a preacher if you haven't
seen this you don't want any spoilers
now it's about time to check out because
we're gonna we're gonna talk more about
this it's a movie I do recommend you
haven't seen it buy it get it on
streaming yeah you know but you know if
you don't care about spoilers and you
know you can stay with us but we're
gonna start talking my spoilers yeah cuz
we're basically just yeah cuz we can't
talk about the movie without spoiling it
yeah well yeah I I've kind of gotten to
the point where I think that's pretty
much true so we're just gonna say that
like you know if you want to watch it
and you don't want that one of the
things I liked about this movie is that
it showed how Dracula became a vampire
and why where he got it from in the old
stories you just think that you kind of
left I believe that he was so evil that
God cursed him with this just out of the
blue now you're a vampire that's not how
this that's not how this [ __ ] happened
no he was in a deadly battle for a long
time his long struggle against Turkey
you know that all the Ottomans and one
day he and a group of guys stumbled
across this cave and they all got wiped
out by this damn monster that was in the
cave and only track of the survivor not
even only Vlad survived
later on he heard a story about that
monster that explained it that it was a
it was a lot bumpier
you know womp here what do you call it
do they call it a bum too one pair of it
didn't really call it a vampire
he was from like ancient Rome wasn't
yeah and like the Roman Empire they had
kind of like this wild man that lived
who was kind of a partly like a sorcerer
he was kind of a kind of reminding them
Daryl from
from the walking dead a little bit but
he was like a medieval version of that
medieval day yeah and he he told he told
Vlad that that this thing that was in
the cave had rules that it was immortal
it was real powerful and the only way it
could die was that if it gave its power
to somebody else yeah it was kind of
like I I kind of got the impression that
the vampires in this movie were like
Highlanders like there can only have one
but maybe not because he made vampires
later on in the movie well I think he
wanted now he made out yet he um it's
just that that that vampire lived in the
cave was so old and so sick of it yeah
he wanted to die because it's like he
asked a demon yeah for power that he got
a power right so he's like the og
vampire right well what is that
happening is that in this battle against
the Ottomans it goes bad for Vlad and he
remembers this like this vampire in the
cave and I'm not gonna spoil every
detail of it but he remembers his
vampire to cave and he says you know I
can get the power I need to win this war
from that vampire yeah it goes in there
and talks with him and it's cool vampire
really no yeah Charles dance play yeah I
think he's just called master vampire
like your credits or whatever so why
they make the exchange and that comes
out of there with all these [ __ ]
badass abilities which explains a lot of
the stuff that you see like say in the
one with Gary Oldman well yeah there was
like a what was that yeah the Francis
Francis Ford Coppola Dracula yeah Bram
Stoker's Dracula I think was what the
actual title that it explains a lot of
stuff that you see that that Dracula do
like for instance he gains the power to
see through the eyes of animals yes so
he could look at you through the forest
you could be anywhere in the forest and
he could access you know he can access
the eyes and the senses of other animals
his vision is really enhanced if you
sling a sword at him he just pops into a
big cloud of damn bats and reforms that
was the raddest yeah that was a really
cool good night to be able to do
um of course he drinks blood and
everything he has to all that August
deal was is that he's gonna have this
blood thirst and if he can hold out for
three days and not drink blood as though
it was it three days three days yeah
then it would it was in his eye did he
go back to normal
go back to normal but of course you know
that he can't he can't control it
because at first it in a way like I
liked that aspect of it cuz I'm like oh
it's kind of like a test drive for
vampire powers like you can just have
them for three days and if you decide
you don't like him yeah but I mean the
bloodlust was so bad that he was in yeah
he was like having to force himself to
keep himself away from his wife and she
was up away from his people because he
wanted to eat them like all the time
well the master vampire of course he
makes a deal but you can see he's pretty
cynical about it because he couldn't
resist it
right so he's like he'd think anyway
yeah and it turns out you can't resist
it because yeah cuz Vlad was all like um
you know no problem bro I just need the
powers for like three days so I can kick
this arms ass so they don't take my kid
or whatever um you know cuz there was
yeah thing what I dunno aspect I liked
about this movie is that they show what
a single vampire could do out in public
fighting an entire army of tens of
thousands of men just wade through them
like their water [ __ ] him up it was bad
that's my bad he single-handedly kills
you twenty thousand guys likes that
scene yeah I liked that scene because
they played it serious it's not like you
know it's not like Vlad's walking off
the castle walls going I got this bro
like wait look like a feet it looked
like a feet that he had to do you know
look it looked kind of difficult it took
a while yeah his dad like he had to be
in places yeah and he starts making
other vampires to help him yeah that
doesn't go well but that happened like
more toward that more poignant
you know as it happens um you know yes
he has all these powers and you know yes
he wipes out a whole [ __ ] army and
stuff like that but once the Sultan like
figures out what he is yeah he starts to
use like use like subterfuge like he's
like okay we'll all put this army here
and let him kick those
we're gonna sneak around behind her get
into his [ __ ] turns out vampires have
a week and it's kind of like Superman
has a weakness for kryptonite vampires
have weakness for silver yeah if you
throw a bunch of silver coins at a dam
for that weekend yes I've never seen
that and that was I that was a good play
well uh as far as I know we even maybe
even farther back in the Middle Ages
that's bombers most supernatural
creatures are resistant to silver
resistant or vulnerable to silver but
well mone yeah maybe like you can like
well it's just like the werewolf but you
have to shoot him with a silver bullet
type that yeah so I don't know why me I
think because silver is like cuz it's
the same color as the moon I don't know
probably yeah it's like some sympathetic
mesh like the way it looks like it looks
like part of a silver moon or so or
something like that and though it was
like supposed to fight the four but I
kind of liked it in the script that the
Sultan didn't put us out he didn't back
down behind the vampire to see he came
up with a solution
yes laid a trap for him baited him into
a big old [ __ ] pile of treasure I
really did like that Zia like when he
just he's like hey come my son I'll
fetch in here and it's like all the
whole floor was covered with stuff and
he had a silver sword too and not only
it
I mean Vlad could still fight but it
like you it made him weak and he
couldn't like see that good like I
showed it from his point of view and it
was like all kind of [ __ ] up yeah he
was like distorted you it is all
straight out of Superman where's
Superman lex luthor you know Superman's
like oh yeah it was like that it was
kind of like that like I said you know
you have to have I mean whether it's a
superhero movie whether it's a horror
movie with like a supernatural creature
they have gotta be weakness because
otherwise well I have a movie why have a
movie it's like well here's this
indestructible thing that's just gonna
kill everyone the end it's like no one
would watch yeah but it looked good the
acting was good made me feel good
watching it you know I mean like the
gestalt of the visual so yeah it had
that dark gothic kind of feel to it when
they were in those castles and yeah and
in the force at night and you got to see
reality through the eyes of a vampire
and you know you got to see a vampire
kick ass and make other vampire
and his abilities were more explained
and that was awesome
I was awesome and answered the questions
I had about Dracula yeah of how he got
dang you wanted to know Brian he really
needed yeah that whole thing that he
willingly became a vampire to win that
war that was a [ __ ] awesome touch
well yeah because he his back was
against the wall didn't know what else
to do
yeah um so he was like hey I heard about
this guy that maybe would make me a
vampire may be real strong so I'm gonna
go and really what that's all about um
you know that's what you would do what
else he didn't have another choice yeah
he had to make that deal because Malaki
was under attack him he didn't have an
army yes that means he had to do it on
his own or he didn't have a big enough
army and like I said they were gonna
kill his kid they were going to take a
bus jammies involved you know they
wanted a tribute of a bunch of boys
right to make them into soldiers and he
said no because it included his kid is
his own son as a hostage well after he
said no then the Sultan said oh well now
I want a thousand and your kid yeah
right after he said now and deal and he
didn't have an army to defend to defend
um you know not a real army he had a
group he had like a security force so
maybe he has sixty guys he needed twenty
thousand yeah by the side of sighs that
army that attacked me and you can turn
into a cloud of bats and flyers
that's right fast yeah you can he
doesn't guys like really really quickly
you couldn't hide from him because the
animals would see you and he could
access that yeah it's just kind of like
that was hinted at well they didn't
bring it up in the original novel it was
kind of hinted but it was kind of hit it
out that he could control a role wolves
and animals could unite animals yeah
that he could commune with them so they
were giving him information he could see
through their eyes
yeah much like I said that coup that
tracks like from the novel that's not
crazy and like I said the silver thing
that's also a very common thing in
folklore it wasn't just the world he
didn't just explode into a cloud of bats
when he got hit it was also rats
yeah I turned an inter changeably of the
bats or rats and I think he turned into
a cloud didn't he yeah he could turn
into a mist and yeah he was Dracula
could do you have to like I said there's
there's nothing in the movie that's not
yeah from that's not like part of the
folklore or is not like hinted at
novel I gotta say like I said the a lot
of the biography of vlad the impaler
about him being raised by the turks like
taken from his family and raised with
them and blah blah blah they used a lot
of that aspect of his biography yeah um
they don't you know they they do say
that he impales dudes on spikes and [ __ ]
like yeah he was doing that as a vampire
too in the movie that's pretty cool but
he does um
I mean he is very much the hero of this
mood he's very sympathetic um you know
he clearly loves his wife and his kid um
and he's trying to protect them so it
doesn't make him look like a monster at
all it makes him look like and him
becoming a vampire is just like I said
it's desperation he's trying to protect
his family he was trying to hold it in
check yeah and the way it went down at
the end which I'm even I'm not gonna
spoil it here but the way that it went
down in the end explains why he's kind
of a depressive recluse in an abandoned
castle when you meet him in Dracula yeah
remember what you because of what
happened yeah to his family and stuff
you know yeah it explains all that I was
gonna say I did liked it I mean should
we spoil because yeah well go ahead cuz
I was gonna say though I mean the whole
point of it he's he trying to like I
said he was trying to fight off this
army which he was doing but then the
Sultan had like you know he knew what
his powers were so he said I'm just
gonna sneak in like I'll have this
smaller force it'll sneak in behind
while you're fighting those people and
he sneaks into the thing and tries to
kidnap his kid and there's like a
struggle and like his wife ends up like
falling off the the wall of the thing
just like in Francis Ford Coppola won
you know falling off and and she does
that's right you know that from Dracula
yeah and she doesn't like she kind of
hits the ground and you know she's dying
and she tells him cuz his three days are
up and she tells him drink my blood and
just you know lay waste you know because
she's like I'm because I'm dead anyway
so you know so that there's that whole
like emotional thing going on too and so
now he's like a vampire forever you know
and he's cursed and everything like that
and after he does that though he turns
like a bunch of his nobles or
or whatever there he turns all of them
into vampires so they just go out and
kick everyone's ass I'm just kill
everybody
yeah male and female vampires out doing
their thing but then he didn't go well
and it's reason being is because his
vampire horde wipes everybody out and
they were gonna eat his kids the only
mortal that was around was his kid and
they were gonna turn on his own son he's
doing it for his kid yeah so the whole
war was about never gonna turn the kids
like hey look he's not like us yeah we
either eat him or we turn him into a
vampire
yeah basically and Dracula's like your
Vlad's like no not having this he's like
actually he wipes my alive he wipes them
all out and then he banishes the kid
banishes himself he says the monk right
that's right that's a human and he's
just like I just take him and don't
bring it back because he was trying to
protect him like I said so that was his
whole motivation like through the whole
movie was just like protecting his wife
and kid um you know his wife got killed
unfortunately but hurt she sacrificed
her life yeah it was you know she was
dying anyway now I'm not sacrificed her
life so he could one thing another thing
that I really liked about the movies
they didn't try to rip off 300 at all
there none of the slow-motion shots none
of the guys trying to read every
Leonidas logic
you could you could tell it has a lot of
CG in it you could tell it has a lot of
that same stuff that was in three but
it's definitely its own movie and it
feels like a gothic vampire movie yeah I
liked it like I said it's it gave me the
same it's similar to underworld yeah but
I like it more she's better than it and
I don't know if you guys know what I'm
talking about missing and I know that
there's been like a lot of sequels to
underworld I only saw the first one and
maybe the second one that I don't really
I actually liked underworld so um I
liked it but I thought it was a little
trihard it was a movie of its time yeah
yeah I feel like it was a little trihard
I shot a girl and everything looked
blueish yeah it had its own motif I feel
like the first matrix was try hard to in
that same way I don't know if you know
you guys know I'm talking about
they were movies at their time I'm again
I'm both like they were movies of the
but I liked this a lot better than
underworld I have yeah Dracula is I like
yeah I think it is because it wasn't the
way it was written is because it links
right in with the Bram Stoker story yeah
so what's that like I mean I liked all
the actors and yeah it's like the way
there was like I said I liked the whole
visual look of it um now let's talk a
little bit about whether this is part of
universals supposed dark universe or not
because no one seems like they can quite
decide what's that I know that is yeah
remember like Universal wanted to start
something called the dark universe they
were gonna reboot all the original like
Universal monster movies Dracula
Frankenstein Wolfman you know mommy
would be a good idea yeah it did sound
like a good idea and when I first heard
about it I'm like oh that's kind of they
wanted to make it like the Marvel
extended cinematic universe except with
all the monsters but they were our dog's
name so it was the law Cheney the launch
and Wolfman is not so in a sense it
would kind of be like penny dreadful but
like updated so they talked about doing
that now for a time like Dracula untold
was supposed to be part of that some
reshoots were done before it came out so
that if they wanted to make it part of
the dark universe later on it with
Lincoln particularly the last scene that
has Charles dance who played the master
vampire who was released from his curse
when he made flat into a vampire like
permanently you know they show them like
in the modern day like in London or
whatever and Charles dance like sees
Vlad like in the present day and starts
like following him so that master
vampire character played by him was
supposed to be like the samuel l.jackson
character like Nick Fury yeah you know
from the MCU
so they're like kind of thinking about
doing that but then it like as the years
went on it seemed like I guess when the
mummy came out and it didn't do I think
this is the toes the stoppers moment
yeah and when it came out and it didn't
do as well as they were hoping I think
they kind of just kind of scuttled that
idea could that movie be considered The
Mummy that's what I mean I wouldn't
never done okay now I'm not gonna the
mummy were supposed to be happening in
the 30s yeah that wouldn't mean Oh Aryan
I am NOT yeah I'm not gonna like I don't
like to [ __ ] on a movie I haven't seen
not [ __ ] not Tom Cruise actually I laugh
at all this area but I am I like Tom
Cruise I know you do I like Tom Cruise
I'm not a fan I've liked him in some
movies but I'm generally not a fan but
I'll watch matters I understand I
understand everything about Tom Cruise I
said I understand Tom Cruise but I still
like it
he's like side the mind I'm inside the
I'm seeing the world through Tom Cruise
I can kind of relate to it it's like
being John Malkovich yeah but he's
crawling into Tom Cruise's okay I'm Tom
Ross I'm not Tom Cruise I'm Tom Ross I'm
not Tom Cruise but I do understand I do
understand Tom Cruise I don't agree with
everything so I don't agree with
everything Tom Cruise but I I do
understand Tom Cruise yeah I understand
Tom Cruise I resonate with him a resume
with the totality of yeah I resonate
with Tom Cruise I understand it you're
hilarious yeah I understand it but I'm
gonna say as I was saying I don't like
to [ __ ] on a movie I haven't seen cuz
that's not cool but from the trailers
I'm like exactly what does that have to
do with the universal mummy movie it
that looks more like the Brent the
Brendan Fraser mummy movies which were
fine but they didn't have anything to do
that was more like an Indiana Jones like
adventure type movie with supernatural
[ __ ] in it which you know those were fun
but this one if it's supposed to be you
know a reboot of the universe of the
hold the dark universe with all the
monsters and stuff like that it didn't
really look like that to me and I think
that might have been why that [ __ ]
didn't go anywhere cuz look here I love
that [ __ ] I love the universal monster
movies I love all that [ __ ] that's not
how you do it though no that's and
that's what I was just gonna say I saw
that trailer and went okay but that's
not the mommy that's not the mummy
right right mommy is a period piece it
is and that's how they should have done
it yeah that's how it should have been
that and honestly like I said it you
know in theory it's a great idea that
you could like make all because there
was a lot of movies in that universe and
there's a lot of [ __ ] you could do with
that but
I kind of feel like they should make
them not in the present day no they told
wasn't it was at the time of lab they
have to be in their periods yeah hurry
it'd be like they could link them all
together some other and you can still
modernize it I mean you could get trade
the 30s and [ __ ] that went down in the
30s in a badass way I mean look right
they were paper train the 1500s in a bad
s ray in this movie look how cool that
was really good yeah I mean I would love
to see a mummy movie that was like the
original act the original with Boris
Karloff in it but like with that look to
it but modernized yeah I mean the color
really ambient real you know and you
could expand on the mythos yeah and
still stay true to the original yeah
I'm because the original movie I mean I
love Boris Karloff I love the original
mummy it is a little slow yeah it is a
little slow and like I said there's so
much you know there's so much mythology
they have to add or you have to yeah and
you could really expand that story out
and now a CG you can you could show
things that he just couldn't show in 30s
yeah especially with the ratings in the
censorship that they had in the 30s to
actually know 30s wasn't as bad as it
was later wrong yeah the Hays Code
didn't come that was was that was why
black cat was so good yeah remember that
one mm-hmm Boris Karloff and Bela Lugosi
Johnson sleeping with other dudes
daughters that was weird that was a
weird ass movie Satanist generals in
their palaces over World War one
battlefields yeah you could get away you
guys had never seen the black cat back
in the 30s watch that [ __ ] yeah it's a
kind of like a film noir horror satanic
or movie they would know they would
never make anything like that in the 50s
never yeah yeah and it's everything sexy
kind of 30s looking women and sheer
outfits and Satanists coming over and
bizarre movie like I said they got away
with a lot of [ __ ] in the third yeah the
fact that they got away with so much
[ __ ] was the reason why they hated this
but it was like no no no we can't have
all of this degeneracy going on
and that yeah and that was not a long
movie I think that was only about 40
minutes very sure they were short back
then you know it's very funny is like
somebody said like when we did the mat
and a review of the the new Tim Burton
Dumbo and I was like well I haven't seen
the commercial the the cartoon in a long
time so I don't remember the original
[ __ ] cartoon the Dumbo movie was only
64 minutes yeah they made some short ass
movies back then and it's funny because
people talk about people now having like
a BD and it's like oh they can't sit
their whole movie it's like [ __ ] man
movies nowadays are like three [ __ ]
hours long right or people will sit
there and watch Netflix for like 12
hours like they'll watch series like it
once so it's like I really don't think
we have a problem with attention span
yeah okay but gotta get back to Dracula
on Toby Jack Toronto I gave it two
thumbs up good one yeah I do
I liked it much much more than I thought
yeah I didn't think was gonna like it
yeah like I said I thought it was gonna
be like underworld that was like I'm
gonna but I pulled me into it within the
first 10 minutes yeah it's like okay all
right yeah and one thing I like about it
too is that it's um I'm not gonna say oh
I like it because it's short but it's
it's exactly as long as it needs to be
it's only about 95 minutes there's no
fat in it it pretty much just goes Bam
Bam Bam I get it it's very tight you
know what I mean there's nothing boring
there's nothing superfluous there's
nothing like that apparently there was a
whole kind of little subplot with Baba
Yaga and I wish they would have put that
in there yeah well it's in the deleted
scenes okay you want to watch that but
that was that whole entire thing was cut
by Baba Yaga Baba Yaga Baba Yaga Baba
Yaga sigh this is a wish and she had a
house that had chicken CFE that Russian
witch because a regular which isn't good
enough for Russia Russia's gotta have a
fucked-up witch house it's kind of she's
got a house it's got chicken feet I'm
just like [ __ ] when I was a kid out of
it Russian movie scared the [ __ ] out of
me
does comment those communist movies that
came out to the United States and the
side numbers I saw it it well actually a
beautiful
Jack Frost which was a Mystery Science
Theater Jack Frost which was a Russo
Finnish connection yeah and Baba Yaga
was in that play Batman yeah
which makes it even scarier yeah she was
she was terrifying and she had this
Shack and it had like these big huge
like chicken feet on the bottom yeah and
it like really makes me wonder here's
the thing about mythology
this is why I'm fascinated by mythology
because you know that there's some kind
of cultural reason why is there a witch
that lives in a house with chicken feet
but because I didn't grow up in that
culture scared to [ __ ] out of you yeah
and I'm just like where the [ __ ] does
that idea even come from like I'm sure
it has like some kind of through lines
like people and then we're like 2 or 3
of these movies one of them was sold as
a Sinbad movie but Russian Sinbad I
don't know but I remember seeing those I
saw as a kid in California in the 70s it
had the Bluebird of happiness it was
they were weird movies and they were I'd
had a womanish head rush and it was a
bird with a woman's head and they were
shocked freaky
beautifully really they were shot
benefit every other and pretty much
everybody in him was pretty yeah pretty
though there are beautiful looking maybe
really good-looking people in it you
know they're beautiful looking movies
it's it that's what's funny it's like
the the Mystery Science Theater episode
of Jack Frost is one of my all-time
favorite episodes just because that
movie it's so crazy and it's like so
pretty to look at I could watch that
without them but with them it's much I'd
like to get a restored blu-ray version
of the movies they're probably weird as
hell they probably look really good I
know I love that [ __ ] I'm very
Harryhausen movies remember that
collection of Ray Harryhausen got all
her [ __ ] how much was that [ __ ] it was
like 30 40 bucks for all that no but
yeah so if you haven't seen Dracula
untold like I said it got it made a lot
of money at the box office but it got
sort of so-so reviews some people were
like oh we should have been more fun all
right we should be more like a super old
[ __ ] pissy ass bitching that those
things it's a good it's just a good
movie just like I enjoyed it quite a bit
and you know like I said even if no dark
universe ever emerges which would be
kind of a bummer but like I said I hope
they do it I hope they do it more like
this and less like the Tom Cruise mommy
there is I suspect yeah I think they did
that the Tom Cribb man getting back and
getting off a subject I'm getting off
topic yeah I'm feeling sorry I'm doc
universe I'm feeling sorry for Cruz
because he always does a good
performance
that was a well-made movie it's just
that that was not really the mummy yeah
like I said it Romani hat was a 30s
period piece and that's how it should've
been a Dean get it wrong when hair when
Howard Carter went and they like hey we
found the tomb in like there's all this
neat stuff in there in this with that
type of stuff I feel like like I said
they tried to make it too much like the
Brendan Fraser like Indiana Jones II
kind of adventure movie and that's not
really with that it that was a different
thing it should have been a slower more
ambient movie with like creep and yeah
[ __ ] Wolfman movie with goddamn
Benicio del Toro in it I don't know I'm
kind of remembering seeing that in the
theater like I remember their heads okay
there hasn't been a and wasn't there an
I Frankenstein I didn't see there hasn't
I saw the Wolfman one now there hasn't
been a good werewolf really movie since
howling one if you ask me have you seen
Dog Soldiers I'm Xena good you would
like dogs okay that's a British werewolf
movie yeah it's not that old that came
out in the 2000s sometime American
Werewolf in London was it was pretty
good I wonder what it was yeah but
there's some but they're not I mean I
liked Ginger Snaps you see it you
haven't seen gingersnaps yeah that was
that was a good girl this is not
dragging on Anto we're drinking and
we're going on you got to get you travel
until it's done in it yeah okay and
again Thank You Sophie for sending us
that like I said I really liked it very
much we had a great time like so Sophie
will probably be a guest on the show I'm
hoping to know she's supposed to come
and visit where to take her to the club
yeah ray and maybe she can be on the
show she's sitting there listening 20
was that May 20th I don't she may be
coming around mate or yeah we'll record
a show gonna be up for a couple days and
then she's gonna go back yes it'll be
super she's visiting a friend in the
area see in this window
yeah but Dracula untold from 2014 check
it out if you haven't already in tell us
what you think about it in the comments
and remember if you like the show like
share subscribe and all your social
media
remember if you'd like to support the
show financially you can go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
calm / 13 o'clock podcast or go to our
blog 13 o'clock podcast on wordpress.com
and there's a little button in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time donation remember
these movie retrospectives just like
this one right here come out every
Friday we have 13 o'clock matinee three
new movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday and regular episodes come
out every Tuesday so check them out if
you haven't already we will see you next
time bye